البدايه مشاهدينا من العراق اللي فيها
حاله غضب وسخط شعبي كبير فيها وخصوصا في
مدينه سامراء التاريخيه التي تابعه
لمحافظه صلاح الدين ونقدر نعنون هذا الغضب
بجمله الخوف من الطائفيه والسبب هو مقام
بيوقف الشيعي في جامع سامراء الكبير ففجاه
انتشر على المنصات بوست للعتبه العسكريه
التابعه للوقف الشيعي قالت في انه راح
تفتح جامع صاحب الامر من بعد ما انتهت من
اعمال ترميم القبه القبه اللي بتتكلم عنها
او بيتكلم عنها هذا الفوز تحديدا هي قبه
جامعه سمراء الكبير وهنا الناس زارت
طائرتها واعتبروا اللي بيعملوه الوقف
الشيعي محاوله للاستيلاء على الجامع
التابع من الاساس للوقف السني ديوان الوقف
السني اصدر فورا بيان استنكر في الموضوع
ووصف خطوه الوقف الشيعي بالاستفزازيه
واعتبرها اغتصاب للاراضي وطالب الجهات
المعنيه بالتدخل لوقف اللي جالس يصير
علماء وعشائر سمراء كمان طلعوا في بيان
صادر عن المجمع الفقهي العراقي وعبروا عن
استيائهم ورفضهم
بالبلد ازمات عنيفه
تكاد تذهب بالبقيه الباقيه من تماسكه
يفاجئنا الجهه المسؤوله عن اعمار العتبه
العسكريه
بتغيير اسم الجامع الكبير في سامراء
محاوله للاستحواذ عليه
بحجه ترميم قبته
وقد حذر رسولنا الكريم
صلى الله عليه وسلم من اغتصاب الارض
فكيف باغتصاب بيوت الله تعالى
فضلا عما سيعقبه من اشعال لنيران الطائفيه
واذكاء للهيبها
توالت البيانات والاستنكارات من مختلف
الجمعيات او الجهات والجمعيات والاحزاب
والتحالفات الدينيه والسياسيه وكمان من
العراقيين والكل كان لسان حاله جمله واحده
كثافه طائفيه وليش ممكن يسووا كذا وايش
الهدف الا اشعال الفتنه امام كل هذا مصدر
اي بيان رسمي او تعليق من الحكومه ولا حتى
الوقف الشيعي طلع رد لكنهم مسحوا البوست
اللي فيه الاسم متغير